you're just gonna burn down your career
and take me with you coin flip get out
of here
what's on your mind today like I want to
change but I'm not particularly open to
make those changes I'm trying every time
I get rid of one compulsion another
compulsion comes up are you yawning
Right Now spoiler alert I feel like I'm
stuck
right
how does that make you feel
foreign
[Music]
Liz hey it's three in the morning I'm
sorry what's in that bowl pretzels the
other Bowl maybe some painkillers maybe
there's painkillers in there yeah I have
to ask is this you forever
I don't know
[Music]
hey Paul I'm worried about you good I
mean grieving here
stop you're doing sad face this is just
face
I have resting dead wife face
and he just kept on going on and on
about how dumb I am but he loves me
your husband is emotionally abusive he's
not working on it he doesn't intend to
just leave him
okay
I think I can help people if I get my
hands a little bit dirtier your mom
wanted you to scatter her ashes right we
know what they should do don't you ever
want to just shake them well we don't
shake them I take that back run huh it
sounds so unethical you're just gonna
burn down your career and take me with
you
coin flip get out of here
right this is my office it took you
longer than it should have my patients
are really thriving this thing I'm doing
is really working I'm right behind you
nobody gets through this life unscathed
I can't remember mom's laugh I can feel
her slipping away
faced with a choice you're gonna let
your grief drown you or are you gonna
face it come through the other side
spark back
I'm just gonna leave your car here I'm a
white guy in Pasadena the cops will
probably just take it back to my house
for me let's be nice
Derek how's it going just walk on the
dog I didn't want my patient moved into
her sister's house sounds like the day's
off to a great start for both of us
[Music]